it's not often that you can look at this
statue high dive
Otto von Bismarck the first Chancellor
of the German Empire towers 34 meters
above the city of Hamburg but up here
we're looking down at him a monumental
bronze statue the personification of
Bavaria in a close-up look
it's an unusual perspective made
possible with a camera mounted on a
drone
they're part of a photo series by Heiner
Miller elsenham that captures many of
Germany's national monuments from on
high
to the 1 garuda Niblick i can get close
to the monuments almost like i'm talking
to them face-to-face it's they get such
a privilege beds and if they turn out
well I hope other people will see them
to prove Anita susan l don venice
killing Dean itself download the city of
Castle is home to another monument an
eight meter tall statue of the Greek
hero Hercules the monument is a UNESCO
World Heritage Site and it's famous for
its architecture but what really
interests Miller elsner is Hercules
character his personality and his face
ascendas fuga Zeke doesn't as for tootin
what do we see in their faces this
Hercules here has a thick beard and a
thick head of hair ha mondaya do who
compare that to Arminius who defeated
the Romans you'd expect him to be a
tough-looking guy but when you get up
there you see he's a real baby face I'm
just a bike adoptive homes dissolves a
delicate face on a battle hardened
warrior it's a contradiction that's not
visible when the statue is viewed from
the ground and this is the figure of
germani on germany's national symbol
surveying the landscape from on high
the drone is guided by remote control a
push of a button releases the shudder
there's always an assistant to to
monitor the radio link it all looks
deceptively simple every drone flight
needs to be approved by the local
authorities wind and weather could cause
the drone to crash and because the drone
costs as much as a family car the crew
really needs to concentrate to wait this
isn't kind of yeoman you could say it's
like a childhood dream that's quite a
bit of money up there it's nerve-racking
and I always breathe a sigh of relief
when I'm done it's all a matter of
practice too but you never know when
something unexpected will happen confess
you madam unexpected the results are
often unexpected to this yacht is
stranded in the dunes just off the North
Sea viewed from the air the beach chairs
are a work of art there is no way to
predict what the final result is going
to be from this vantage point it's a
different world this Cathedral in palma
de majorca is a true landmark many of
the photos are taken at sunrise or
sunset motor elsner has to work fast to
capture the perfect image
Gina through Peavy Gong that a drone
flies between six and twelve minutes
depending on the weather if I try to get
as many images as I can one from
overhead one from the side that's I have
to work fast and catch the light goodbye
if you've already flown eight minutes
and ascent again the rooftops are
already dark careful choise conditions
were tricky during the Hercules shoot
too there was a strong wind but in the
end the drone came eye to eye with
Hercules it's a compelling image this
Fatima and unhappiness is cloud Chile's
has a fascinating facial expression not
my best it's thrilling much more
interesting than what we can see from
down here like to me that slightly
fierce look on his face it really rounds
out the series the gentle looking
Arminius the fierce Hercules you got it
all Haku justice justice from the
contraband fighter piner Miller elsner
already has a new idea for his next
project a photo series of his home town
of hamburg also from a bird's-eye view
of course
you